any reading tips for becoming teachers
who don't want to be corrupted by the
current teacher education at the
universities well I would say you know
you can I have a reading list on my book
on my website Jordan be Peter super calm
you could go look there I'm gonna add
some more books to it read as much
classic literature as you can read
history like go into the libraries and
and and look at great books programs
that's what I would say and you have to
educate yourself at the University you
know I mean that's always being the case
and it's even more the case now is is go
back and go back and read great integer
great philosophy great thinkers and you
will learn a tremendous amount that way
and I I think otherwise there's no way
you can avoid being corrupted by the
current teacher education at
universities the education faculties are
absolutely dreadful absolutely dreadful
so